Since we primarily need the generateMove
method for initializing a turn for
the computer,
let's write a custom init method that
initializes a turn with a random move.
We'll add that custom in that
method to the RPSTurn class.
I'm going to start by copying and
pasting in the initWithMove method and
then I'll change the name to init.
And we're not going to be passing
in any parameters this time.
And then we'll initialize the move
property with the value returned by
generateMove.
With this construction, we're sending
the message generateMove to self.
And again, here self is
a pointer to the RPSTurn object.
And now this line in the throwDown
method will initialize the variable
ComputersTurn with a value for
its move property.
What if we place a break point after
computersTurn, we can run this and
then inspect the value of that variable
in the left side of the console.
So we press Run and then we see
our variables here on the left
side of the console and
the value for move is Paper.
Now let's run it again.
This time it's scissors,
we'll run it again.
This time it's rock.
So our init method is doing a good
job of generating random moves for
ComputersTurn.